et maintenant je vais prononcer d'autres
non est-ce qu'on va accueillir le jury
de ce 64e festival de cannes
il ya deux ans elle a reçu le grand prix
pour son premier long métrage atlantique
qui donne forme aux fantômes de notre
monde contemporain
son cinéma est engagé et engageant
politique et poétique
la réalisatrice mati diop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on sait sa passion pour le cinéma
et l'inspiration qu'elle y puise on
comprend pourquoi ces chansons sont des
histoires ses clips sont des films et
elle est une artiste unique
mylène farmer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors moi la première fois que je
l'avais vu c'était d'encre et dia et je
trouvais que c'était une des filles les
plus cool qui soit elle peut jouer tous
les rôles et elle s'en sert pour faire
des choix
l'actrice est jeune réalisatrice mag il
n' roll
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est aussi discrète que son cinéma
est déterminé la dernière fois qu'elle
est et dans cette salle c'était pour
présenter little joe la réalisatrice
jessica hausner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle fut l'innocence incarner au mieux
de bâtard pas vraiment glorieux
depuis elle réalise des films aux états
unis à l'agitée conscient sur
l'environnement et elles dansent sur le
tapis rouge
c'est la fille qui a peur de rien
l'actrice et réalisatrice mélanie
laurent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lors de l'autre côté de l'atlantique de
mati diop il ya un homme qui a été deux
fois en compétition à cannes
ambassadeurs d'un grand territoire de
cinéma le brésil il est là vivent et
résistant le réalisateur qui permettent
de safilo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on avait découvert en prison à cannes
avec un prophète
cette année on le retrouve dans le camp
de guantanamo avec notre invité
d'honneur
entre les deux il a pu exercer son
métier en toute liberté et avec une
exigence qui force le respect l'acteur
tahar rahim
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien ma foi que les vues il se cacher
sous la table basse
c'était dans parasites palme d'or du
festival de cannes en 2019 l'acteur song
kang ho
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]